el otro día seguido de contagios el
récord aquí en el Reino Unido con
119789 nuevos casos se conocen
resultados preliminares pero alentadores
sobre los efectos de Omicron esta
variante que está causando tanta
incertidumbre en todo el mundo según la
Agencia de Seguridad Sanitaria británica
quiénes se contagian con esta variante
Omicron tienen entre un 50 y un 70%
menos probabilidades de necesitar
atención hospitalaria frente a quienes
tienen otras variantes como la del está
también tienen entre un 31 y un 45%
menos probabilidades de necesitar ir a
urgencias sin embargo por el tsunami de
contagios de un micro en este país es
probable que las hospitalizaciones el
número de hospitalizaciones todavía sea
alto que probable y eventualmente pueda
poner en riesgo el Sistema Nacional de
Salud
otro lado hemos escuchado hace varios
días por diferentes fuentes científicas
que para luchar contra esta variante
Omicron es necesaria una tercera dosis
de vacunas pues hoy está Agencia
Sanitaria británica establecido además
que la protección de esta tercera dosis
acá entre un 15 y un 25% después de la
semana 10 sin embargo los científicos
resaltan que este panorama es mucho
mejor que no tener vacunas y estar a la
deriva de desarrollar posibles efectos
incluso la muerte por este covit19